bonsoir à tous bienvenue voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce vendredi 24
avril une décision et beaucoup de
commentaires aujourd'hui le juge fabrice
burgaud s'est vu infliger une simple
réprimande par ses pairs alors bouc
émissaire sanction de compromis
personne ne semble vraiment satisfait
sept ans après le fiasco judiciaire
d'outreau
le chômage des moins de 25 ans inquiète
650 mille jeunes seront prochainement à
la recherche d'un emploi à nicolas
sarkozy a présenté aujourd'hui un plan
d'urgence sur la question nous verrons
quelles ont été les mesures annoncées
une tentative de braquage d'un fourgon
de la brink's ce matin à
tremblay-en-france en seine-saint-denis
deux des trois malfaiteurs ont été
blessées et l'information qui interpelle
dans cette affaire c'est qu'ils sont
tous mineurs le plus jeune a même 14 ans
et demi la question du vendredi nous
parlerons ce soir de l'immobilier la fin
de la bulle est ce le moment des bonnes
affaires
les prix et les taux d'emprunt sont à la
baisse à suivre également notre enquête
sur la difficulté encore et toujours de
louer un appartement
le sport et la natation avec la finale
du 100 m nage libre des championnats de
france et au lendemain de son record du
monde d'alain bernard a été battu
aujourd'hui vous le verrez par son rival
frédérick bousquet enfin nous parlerons
d'un temps que les moins de 20 ans 30
ans ne devrait pas connaître et pourtant
la comédie musicale starmania et
toujours aussi moderne starmania qui
fête ce soir sur france 2 son
anniversaire est avec nous celle qui
pilotera sur rendez vous france gall est
notre invité bonsoir à tous merci d'être
avec nous et on commence ce soir par une
question que faut-il penser de la
sanction infligée par le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature aujourd'hui
au juge fabrice burgaud après avoir été
reporté la décision est finalement
tombée et c'est une simple réprimande
qui lui a été signifié pour son
instruction de l'affairé d'outreau
une décision qui je vous le disais en
titre a suscité de nombreuses réactions
sept ans après ce terrible fiasco
judiciaire
dominique verdeilhan christophe vignal
la chancellerie avait demandé à un an de
suspension c'est une réprimande avec
inscription au dossier la plus basse
sanctions prévues par la loi
fabrice burgaud peut continuer d'exercer
au parquet de paris
défaut de maîtrise négligences
maladresses pour le csm leur
accumulation constitue un manque de
rigueur caractérisé de nature à nuire au
bon déroulement de la formation est un
manquement aux devoirs de son état de
juge d'instruction
pour les avocats de fabrice burgaud
c'est une décision politique pour plaire
à l'opinion publique pas je trouve aussi
curieux que alors que le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature devait
rendre cette décision aujourd'hui
le président de la république se soit
encore prononcée sur la responsabilité
des magistrats il ya quelques jours
si vous n'appelez pas cela une pression
sur sept au stade ce sens les mots n'ont
plus de sens les avocats annoncent un
recours devant le conseil d'état
de leur côté les acquittés d'outreau se
disent déçus c'est pas une sanction on
dit pas à monsieur bio vous êtes trompés
vous avez quand même fait beaucoup de
mal et vous avez fait des trois erreurs
donc on vous sanctionne on lui dit pas
ça aujourd'hui
il a fait n'importe quoi c'est donc pour
les juges on peut se permettre n'importe
quoi on ne risque rien quand donc là je
trouve tout de même que ce à quoi je
crois que il aurait dû être démis
suspendu à vie ne plus être magistrat
j'estime que fabrice burgaud vu comment
il a fait son instruction n'a pas à être
dans la magistrature
cette décision fait aussi des vagues au
csm on a appris cet après midi que l'un
de ses membres est intervenue comme
magistrat dans le dossier outreau après
le départ du juge burgaud résultats
l'intéressé a immédiatement été
convoqués par le président du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
cette affaire maintenant les faits se
sont déroulés ce matin à
tremblay-en-france en seine-saint-denis
un fourgon de la brink's a été braquée
et convoyeurs ont ouvert le feu deux des
trois malfaiteurs ont été blessées puis
interpellé et les enquêteurs ont très
vite révélé qu'ils étaient tous mineurs
le plus jeune d'entre eux
14 ans lionel feierstein olivier robert
il s'était réfugié dans cette tour chez
des amis au bout de trois heures de
négociations
ils ont fini par se rendre aux policiers
du raid blessé par balle à la jambe et
au bras
deux des trois braqueurs ont été
hospitalisés des braqueurs extrêmement
jeunes âgés de 16 15 et 14 ans ce matin
cagoulés lunettes de soleil sur le nez
il braque ce fourgon blindé avec des
bombes lacrymogènes
un transporteur de fonds riposte et tire
les adolescents s'enfuit à pied sans le
butin jusqu'à un immeuble voisin
les j'ai entendu des coups de feu mme
asma grande crise et j'ai entendu les
gens les gens clinton dimanche lorsque
celui-ci met le pied
les adolescents sévèrement blessé il
monte dans les étages puis se cachent
plusieurs heures dans cet appartement où
les policiers les arrêtent bien que
connu pour des faits de délinquance dont
le braquage d'une pharmacie leur
témérité d'aujourd'hui surprend les
policiers aussi jeune et avoir redire le
culot de s'attaquer à fourgon blindé
c'est relativement exceptionnel car ce
type d'agression souvent liée au grand
banditisme
une enquête sur les circonstances de
l'assaut a été ouverte le transporteur
de fonds affirme avoir tiré en état de
légitime défense
il aurait vu une arme l'inconscience des
jeunes braqueurs a failli leur coûter la
vie
l'économie il ya des chiffres qui
marquent et celui du chômage des jeunes
en france fait partie de cela chez les
moins de 25 ans le taux de chômage
atteint désormais plus de 20%
ils sont les premières victimes de la
crise une situation qui a poussé
l'exécutif a lancé un plan d'urgence
nicolas sarkozy a présenté ce matin
plusieurs mesures accompagnées d'une
enveloppe de plus d'un milliard d'euros
le point sur tout cela avec romain
beauty et bruno vignes et c'est devant
des jeunes en formation que nicolas
sarkozy dévoile ce matin son plan
d'urgence
au total cinq cent mille jeunes sont
concernés par ce plan qui devrait coûter
à l'état un milliard trois cents
millions d'euros l'argent
public je pas qui serve à financer du
chômage je veux qu'ils servent à
financer de la formation des emplois je
ne suis pas venu vous promettre des
indemnités de chômage
le gouvernement mise sur un dispositif
qui a déjà fait ses preuves
la formation en alternance premier volet
l'apprentissage dès aujourd'hui et
pendant un an les entreprises qui
embaucheront des apprentis seront
exonérées de charges et verront leur
aide
augmentez exemple les pme de moins de 50
salariés percevant une aide de 1800
euros par apprenti pour les contrats de
professionnalisation l'état versera
entre 1000 et 2000 euros de primes aux
entreprises pour toute embauche d'un
jeune de moins de 26 ans enfin coup de
pouce pour les stagiaires une
rémunération devient obligatoire à
partir de deux mois contre trois
auparavant et pour toute embauche d'un
stagiaire en cdi avant septembre
l'entreprise touchera une prime
exceptionnelle de 3000 euros
le plan devrait être présenté aux
syndicats dès mardi prochain est
l'objectif fixé par le chef de l'état
avec ses aides financières et donc de
favoriser le recrutement de plus de 320
milles jeunes apprentis d'ici juin 2010
l'apprentissage est une piste
privilégiée car elle permet vous allez
le voir d'obtenir des résultats bien
concret et notamment grâce aux contrats
de professionnalisation
reportage fabien shadow marie cros ils
ont entre 20 et 25 ans certains
reviennent sur les bancs de l'école
mais dans cette classe ils apprennent un
métier technicien chauffagiste
l'enseignement ici et concret choses en
place l'utilisation des machines et
aussi les ficelles du métier c'est quoi
le secret lui les parages
on se passe pas sur les outils au
dernier moment où commence à observer
l'autre partie de la formation c'est sur
le terrain en entreprise
ils ont un contrat et gagnent en moyenne
900 euros par mois à la tête sortie
l'angle est un fait ou haut niveau les
profils sont différents chômeurs
diplômés tous viennent chercher une
formation pratique pour être tout de
suite opérationnels vertement la sortie
d'école aller un peu assurés parce qu'on
a comme un après beaucoup de choses et
on a manipulé beaucoup de deux machines
et là on a un hacker plus beaucoup
d'informations le contrat de
professionnalisation existe depuis 2004
l'an dernier 145 mille jeunes en ont
bénéficié
70 % d'entre eux sont aujourd'hui en cdi
c'est le cas de rabat il a terminé sa
formation il ya tout juste un an second
aujourd'hui les chauffagistes et gagnent
plus de 1500 euros par mois
une réussite ce qu'il estime avoir
mérité la première contrainte c'est
qu'il faut se remettra à étudier donc
quand on a un parcours parfois hachées
par le travail par le chômage
il faut reprendre le cycle en fête de
l'école donc c'est pas toujours facile
rabat 10 a désormais un métier entre les
mains son objectif aujourd'hui
progresser dans la hiérarchie de son
entreprise et bâtir un vrai plan de
carrière
un autre chiffre du jour celui de la
consommation des ménages qui est reparti
à la hausse au mois de mars plus 1,1
pour cent du côté de bercy on reste
cependant prudent convalescence de
l'économie devrait je cite durer encore
plusieurs trimestres
le parti socialiste entre en campagne ce
soir pour les européennes à toulouse
premier grand meeting élargi à ses
partenaires de l'union
l'occasion de retrouver martine aubry la
première secrétaire que certains
militants trouvent parfois un peu trop
en retrait plus discrète plus
silencieuse que d'autres sur place et la
nuque dans numério l'europe sociale sera
au coeur de la campagne des socialistes
pour les européennes
une rencontre avec les salariés de molex
a donc valeur de symbole pour protester
contre la fermeture annoncée de leur
usine ils ont séquestré deux de leurs
dirigeants en début de semaine martine
aubry déplore mais comprend
je n'aime pas les violences mais il ya
un moment donné où il faut se dire que
faut-il faire pour être entendu une loi
on en prend aujourd'hui pour empêcher
les bandes pour empêcher que des enfants
se réunissent dans des cours d'immeuble
par les ferait mieux de prendre des
mesures pour empêcher des entreprises
sans aucune raison économique de
licencier la politique du gouvernement
en accusation celle de bruxelles
également
je crois que le molex villemur cette
semaine c'est un scandale aussi d'un
point de vue de politique européenne
le ton est donné la campagne sera donc
française et européenne
une première pour le coup d'envoi les
leaders socialistes des 27 pays de
l'union se sont rassemblés à toulouse
avec un programme et une ambition
commune
beaucoup de français qui s'inquiètent
aujourd'hui d'une europe trop libérale
d'une europe que la droite a appelé
partir partir de ce que sont ses valeurs
de base et bien les français aujourd'hui
ça qu'on ne peut pas seul tout changé et
qu'il faut changer là bas pour changer
après les socialistes rassemblés en
europe mais aussi une la france la
réconciliation entre martine aubry et
ségolène royal avant sa greffe à elles
défileront côte à côte le 1er mai
prochain à paris avant de tenir un
meeting commun à la fois comment
imaginer qu'un trader ait pu prendre des
positions d'un montant de plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros sans que
sa banque aient pu ne pas être au
courant cette question vous l'êtes peut
être déjà posé bien elle est mise en
avant aujourd'hui par le nouvel avocat
de jérôme kerviel
celui ci souhaite relancer l'instruction
qui pourtant touche à sa fin il pointe
ainsi du doigt la société générale
seulement est ce que cette position
repose sur quelque chose
en tout cas les avocats de la banque eux
ont leur réponse
pierre monnet gier frédéric basket
jérôme kerviel at il pu agir à l'insu de
ses employeurs l'ex-trader avait fait
perdre 5 milliards d'euros à la société
générale
en brassant des dizaines voire des
centaines de milliards pour son nouvel
avocat la banque était forcément au
courant
il ya dans toute vente un écran
informatique sûr qu'elles apparaissent
tous les mouvements identifiés par
trader place des marques et j kerviel
on savait qu'il s'agissait et en face on
verra sur un cumul total il engagé 800
milliards d'euros soit deux fois le
budget de la france au nom de la société
générale et celle ci dit qu'elle n'a pas
su qu'elle n'a pas vu c'est
invraisemblable la défense de kerviel
demande aux juges de nommer des experts
indépendants pour déterminer précisément
ce que savait la société générale selon
l'avocat de la banque
il s'agit d'une simple manoeuvre
destinée à repousser la tenue du procès
tout a été examinés par les juges
d'instruction depuis maintenant un an et
par tous les avocats qui se sont succédé
au nom de monsieur kerviel pour retarder
les échéances on s'aperçoit que tout a
été dissimulé et très bien dissimulée
par jérôme kerviel
si les magistrats refusent de prolonger
l'instruction jérôme kerviel pourrait
être jugé dans les tout prochains mois
il encourt jusqu'à cinq ans de prison et
375 mille euros damende dans l'actualité
à l'étranger cette alerte à la grippe
porcine au mexique une cinquantaine de
personnes décédées font l'objet
actuellement d'analysés les autorités
sanitaires s'inquiètent d'un risque
d'épidémie le gouvernement n'a pas
hésité à lancer une vaste campagne de
vaccination et à fermer les écoles et
les universités de la capitale cette
affaire inquiète également depuis
quelques heures les états unis jose
blanc la pierre
a mexico 'l'annonce fait la une des
journaux fermeture des écoles pour jean
sanitaires dans les rues il est
recommandé de se protéger d'éviter les
lieux publics et si possible de rester
chez soi la mairie a décidé une campagne
de vaccination massive
en effet le mexique doit faire face à
une épidémie de grippe porcine un virus
qui habituellement ne se transmet pas à
l'homme est aujourd'hui responsable de
16 morts
l'origine de 50 autres cas mortels est à
l'étude
d'autres contrôles sont en cours sur
plus de 900 malades
les symptômes sont une fièvre d'au moins
39 degrés qui survient subitement une
tour de forme de tête des douleurs aux
muscles et articulations des yeux hérité
et le nez qui coule
l'inquiétude est venue des états unis de
l'autre côté de la frontière où sept cas
de grippe porcine ont été détectés cinq
en californie et deux au texas
des personnes relativement jeunes et qui
ont été soignés depuis les autorités
sanitaires mondiales sont un mal être
beaucoup d'information doivent encore
être clarifiés
la transmission du virus ou comment les
gens peuvent être exactement atteint
nous attendons les résultats de notre
laboratoire de mexico mais pour
plusieurs critères c'est inhabituel et
il faut être prudent
la dernière grande épidémie de grippe
porcine a eu lieu en 1976 aux états unis
la france a toujours été épargné
autre inquiétude militaires cette fois
direction le pakistan les talibans ne
cesse d'accroître leur présence et leur
influence dans une province du pays qui
n'est située qu'à une centaine de
kilomètres de la capitale aujourd'hui
cependant les représentants de la
mouvance islamiste ont annoncé un début
de retrait de leurs positions dans le
nord ouest du pays
mais faut-il vraiment les croire amaury
guibert c'est la parade des talibans
pakistanais
ces combattants islamistes sont pourtant
en train de se retirer du district de
buner
mais ce repli n'a rien d'une défaite ils
savent qu'ils sont en position de force
à 100 kilomètres seulement de la
capitale islamabad
en face c'est quelques paramilitaires
sont à remparts bien dérisoire certains
ont d'ailleurs déserté et la communauté
internationale craint maintenant que les
autorités pakistanaises n'abdique devant
les extrémistes voulons les soutenir les
aider comme nous le pouvons mais il faut
qu'elle prenne conscience des menaces
qui pèsent sur leur pays
critique à peine voilée de l'accord
passé entre le pouvoir central et les
talibans en échange d'un cessez le feu
ils ont obtenu l'application de la
charia dans leurs bastions flagellation
exécutions publiques le retour de
pratiques d'un autre âge
les talibans font désormais la loi ils
ont les coudées franches pour se
préparer à la prochaine offensive
il est 20 heures 14 merci d'être avec
nous à suivre dans votre journal du
nouveau dans l'affairé lise et si les
parents de l'enfant arriver finalement à
trouver un terrain d'entente
le marché de l'immobilier ne serait plus
en crise mais peut-on vraiment parler de
reprise
et puis france gall fait ce soir sur
france 2 les 30 ans de starmania y sera
avec nous tout à l'heure pour nous
parler de tout cela
mais avant cela je vous le disais les
choses semblent avancer à petits pas
dans l'affairé lise la mère de l'enfant
a accepté aujourd'hui de comparaître
finalement devant la justice française
et son ex mari lui a rencontré dans la
journée le médiateur russe en charge du
dossier
ça s'est passé avignon indeed boudaoud
et christophe la roque à l avenir de la
petite élise s'est peut être jouée
aujourd'hui à avignon dans le patio d'un
hôtel de luxe le père jean michel andré
s'est entretenu avec le médiateur russe
chargé de régler le conflit qui l'oppose
à son épouse après une pause déjeuner et
cinq heures de discussions une solution
s'esquisse irina belenkaïa la maman
accepte de comparaître devant la justice
française
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire qu irina
belenkaïa est prête à un compromis
elle regrette beaucoup ce qui s'est
passé georges coste ritchie on ne
connaît pas encore les termes exacts de
l'accord mais aujourd'hui le père
d'élise a pris lui aussi des engagements
je ferai tout ce qui est de mon ressort
pour éviter à la maire de lille de se
retrouver ou même de continuer à être en
prison
et ça doit se faire dans un cadre qui me
dépasse largement
je ne suis pas juge suspecté d'avoir
enlevé sa fille irina belenkaïa est en
détention provisoire à budapest
en attendant une éventuelle extradition
vers la france nous l'avons rencontré
hier dans sa prison elle nous a confirmé
son accord de principe sur une garde
partagée mais du bout des lèvres inside
and or if there is a good salle au fond
c'est après deux années de déchirements
la mère et le père de la petite élise
semble désormais bien décidé à trouver
un terrain d'entente dans l'intérêt de
l'enfant
les questions du vendredi maintenant et
voyons ce soir comment se porte
l'immobilier en cette période de crise
on évoque une reprise du marché nous
parlerons des prix à l'achat avec notre
invité
mais aussi des taux d'emprunt est ce le
moment de les négocier mais avant cela
vous allez voir qu'il est toujours aussi
difficile de louer un appartement
un parcours du combattant avec aurélia
bros et marquent deux langues à dagana
un deux pièces à louer au coeur de paris
c'est une denrée rare
alors ils sont tous arrivés en avant ce
rendez vous l' agence immobilière a fait
venir une quinzaine de personnes pour
visiter le même appartement pattes
rouges dit le fait d'arriver tous en
même temps
comme vous l'avez dit une grosse demande
donc à chaque fois on est ne renvoie 3.3
pas de temps à perdre
la visite se fera en quelques minutes à
tour de rôle on va faire entrer les
quatre premières personnes
allez si je vous en prie au bout de cet
étroit couloir un petit deux pièces avec
quelques réparations à faire je vous
rappeler un petit peu les conditions
financières
on a deux pièces 36 m² donc on a un
loyer charges comprises à 834 euros
834 euros pour 36 mètres carrés ces 23
euros du mètre carré un peu plus que la
moyenne dans la capitale pour décrocher
l'appartement
il faut un salaire net trois fois
supérieur au prix du loyer et la
concurrence est rude
même avec un bon dossier j'en ai déjà
visité pavane ses attractions son
appartement sur paris j'ai un dossier
qui est bon ou mauvais et donc c'est pas
uniquement une question de goût de la
pour l'appartement c'est aussi multiplié
les chances pour navin un nom qui nous
plaît onex on peut être 50 sur le
département donc fournie on est en bas
de l'escalier l'appartement déjà pris
pour des petites surfaces et parents
sont vu renvoyer il faut beaucoup le
garant ou sociaux ont des revenus des
cdi et va pas toujours le dossier
c'est la clé de voûte de la recherche
d'appartement et pour espérer être l'élu
il faut avoir de solides garant pour ce
deux pièces revisitées de dossiers
déposés sains retient déjà l'attention
la joie que le gard les propriétaires
vie derrière une taxe foncière c'est un
peu le profil qu'on cherche
exigez des garants si le bailleur a
souscrit une assurance loyers impayés et
que le locataire un salaire suffisant
c'est aujourd'hui illégale mais les
agences préfère se couvrir au maximum
le but pour le propriétaire comme pour
nous en tant qu'agence assez justement
de queuleu la location spa se passe ça
se passe dan pas faire jouer l'assurance
donc on prend le maximum de garanties à
la base pour pour que la location se
passe bien sûr là sur la durée du bail
d'autres agences elles n'hésitent pas à
demander des chèque de réservation pour
le logement des certificats de mariage
ou même la carte vitale pour la
constitution du dossier
une pratique illégale mais impuni nous
maintenons un spécialiste de
l'immobilier bernard cadeau président du
réseau orpi bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous on vient de le voir c'est si
difficile de convaincre un propriétaire
de louer son appartement
les critères de sélection semble
vraiment de plus en plus dur
alors bien sûr c'est difficile mais je
voudrais dire quand même que le marché
locatif français ne reflète pas tout à
fait le marché parisien puisque paris
c'est un petit peu quelque chose à part
c'est vrai que c'est difficile
maintenant nous pouvons considérer qu'il
ya une détente sur le marché de la
location qui est en train de s'amorcer
pour deux raisons principales la
première ses clés les bailleurs privés
reviennent sur le marché de l'immobilier
les particuliers achètent des biens pour
les louer c'est donc une bonne nouvelle
qui va détendre un petit peu ce marché
est amené plus d'offre locative et puis
il ya comme ça a été mentionné dans
votre reportage des garanties de
paiement de loyer avec une petite
dernière si je peux dire qu'ils
s'appellent la garantie des revenus
locatifs ou l'état apporte sa propre
caution donc ce sont des facteurs qui
devraient à terme d'étendre un petit peu
ce marché locatif français bernard cas
de la chute de l'immobilier a eu tout de
même pour conséquence la fermeture de
nombreuses agences c'était comme une
bulle finalement il y avait trop
d'agencés elles étaient en surnombre
je crois qu'il ya eu surtout beaucoup
d'ouvertures d'agencés pendant la
période où le marché immobilier a été
très très porteur c'est à dire la
période entre 1997 et 2007 et que
manifestement ce grand nombre de
ouverture d' agences ne correspondait
pas à la volumétrie du marché et lorsque
la crise financière qui a frappé toute
la planète et bien sûr la france l'année
dernière au milieu de l'année dernière
c'est arrivé elle a impacté le marché de
l'immobilier il ya eu moins de ventes
globalement sur l'ensemble du territoire
et naturellement ces agences
nouvellement ouvertes on rencontrait des
difficultés et un certain nombre d'entre
elles ont fermé alors rapidement où en
est le marché le marché justement
actuellement on enregistre une reprise
ou pas oui il ya clairement une reprise
très très clairement le marché de
l'immobilier n'a jamais été dans d'aussi
bonnes dispositions depuis les 18
derniers mois pourquoi parce que d'une
part les prix de l'immobilier ont baissé
et d'autre part les taux d'intérêt ont
baissé
nous considérons nous que la baisse des
taux d'intérêt a permis de récupérer
autour de 15% de pouvoir d'achat pour
les clients acquéreurs les candidats
acquéreurs c'est non négligeable et nous
remarquons nous observons dans les
agents sur le terrain une reprise de
l'activité des contacts parce que le le
besoin de logements et est un besoin
très réveillés très fort en france et
l'envié de logements également
cela veut dire qu'on doit aujourd'hui
négocier les prix et aussi négocié son
taux je crois surtout qu'il faut trouver
le bon logement pour réaliser son bon
projet je voulais dit les prix ont
baissé parfois ils ont besoin encore
d'être un petit peu ajustées
mais c'est surtout faire la bonne
synthèse entre le produit que l'on va
acheter les conditions dans lesquelles
on va l'acheter le taux d'intérêt bien
sûr puisque c'est un élément important
il ya aussi là je dirais une concurrence
entre les établissements financiers
et pourquoi pas faire jouer cette cette
concurrence c'est faire cette bonne
synthèse et cette bonne analyse de son
projet immobilier je crois merci
beaucoup bernard cadeau dans un instant
nous retiendrons france gall mais avant
cela le sport avec ce soir de la
natation et la finale du 100 m nage
libre des championnats de france qui
avait une fois encore un parfum de
rendez vous mondial alors alain bernard
a t'il renouveler son exploit d'hier la
réponse avec manuel tissier voici
l'homme qui a fait chuter alain bernard
et pleuré de joie laure manaudou sa
compagne
frédérick bousquet 28 ans champion de
france du 100 m nage libre avant la
course
habillé de son ancienne combinaison et
de son record du monde d'alain bernard
paraissait imbattable sous les yeux de
coralie balmy sa fiancée à lui les
lignes de numéro 7 bousquet vêtu d'une
combinaison nouvelle génération prend le
meilleur départ
le sprinteur qui vit aux états unis avec
laure manaudou est passé tout près du
record du monde de bernard symbolisée
par la ligne rouge
47 secondes 15 centièmes il réalise le
troisième chrono de l'histoire du 100 m
alain bernard a maintenant de la
compagnie au sommet du sprint mondial
l'équipe de france n'a jamais été aussi
forte c'est une contagion c'est tout
rappel en un an avant d'aller à l'epo ça
c'est des moments rares qu'on apprécie
énormément en tant qu'athlète battant la
bagarre cet été dans la course au titre
cet été les deux nageurs se disputeront
le titre mondial à rome est peut-être le
record
ils ont trois mois pour trouver la
combinaison gagnante
c'est l'événement ce soir sur france 2
stars manière fête son trentième
anniversaire 30 ans déjà et des tubes
qui sont toujours là étrangement moderne
et ils vont être revisités lors d'une
soirée que vous allez nous présenter et
france gall bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous ce soir
on se voit pas souvent juste première
question comment allez-vous ça va bien
très bien vous préférez toujours l'ombre
à la lumière
oui toujours mais mais j'aime la musique
plus que tout et le fait de faire ce
show sur la musique de michel c'est un
grand bonheur un vrai bonheur
c'est vraiment un peu prémonitoire
starmania trente ans après le blues du
businessman tout ça c'est ces étranges
toujours ça résonne aujourd'hui en tout
cas encore c'est fou c'est fou je sais
pas comment deux personnes qui ont à
peine 30 ans ont imaginé le monde
d'aujourd'hui avec trente ans avant ce
tournoi commence à peine mais en tous
les cas ils ont bien réussi ce qu'il
voulait faire et en plus en temps après
on les écoute toujours comme si c'était
hier
alors on va l'écouter justement ce qui
va se passer soir et puis on va se
retrouver juste après quelques extraits
et a tout de suite
pour m
enfin
moi
avant et deux en même temps
si vous cassez
on
c'est pas demandé
rires
je voudrais seulement six reprises
je m'en veux craint tout le monde
bien que je fais
amel bent effectivement christophe
willem une formidable version monopolis
éblouissante version c'était une chanson
que je chantais donc une wii une chanson
pour voix féminines et lui voue
grandiose
il est arrivé à la faire de manière
qu'ils avaient choisi un peu ce casting
nouvelle génération mélange des deux
d'ailleurs ce soir aussi diane dufresne
oui ben mêlant mélange des deux parce
que je
je pense que c'est intéressant de revoir
ce qu'ils ont créé et puis les nouvelles
voix parce que c'est un show pour les
jeunes
et enfin pour tout le monde mais ça a
été écrit par des jeunes c'est un opéra
rock et donc il fallait des chanteurs
jeunes et pour chanter et aussi parce
que c'est très difficile à chanter il
faut être au maximum de ses possibilités
pour faire taire manière a été facile
pour ces deux hommes les 30 ans de se
lancer dans cette aventure c'était très
facile parce que ils avaient tellement
envie et son fils cru on dans le projet
les producteurs sont du bon allez on y
va
non non non il a fallu les convaincre
mais il a suffi que ils jouent eux-mêmes
tous les deux c'est à dire un jour il a
fallu que luc plamondon raconte
l'histoire avec michel à côté au piano
qui faisaient toutes les chansons et ce
jour là c'est comme ça que ça a commencé
en fait c'est eux qui ont joué pour la
première fois starmania dans son
intégralité et se traversent les
générations
j'ai même lu que françois mitterrand
était fan absolument
il aimait s'y de la belle musique et et
c'est un spectacle extraordinaire et
donc des jeux dont prince charles et
lady diana je crois absents 88 alors on
va passer une très belle soirée avec
vous la chanson j'ai cru comprendre que
c'était terminé entre eux entre
parenthèses sauf si quelqu'un vous
propose quelque chose mais je sais pas
si c'est quelqu'un qui peut me proposer
je ne sais pas je ne peux pas répondre à
cette question c'est cette terrible
affaire à suivre
en tout cas on va suivre ce soir vous en
tant que présentatrice télé en tout cas
ça vous plaît j'ai pris votre place si
ma très bien côté on va suivre ça ce
soir merci beaucoup
france gall starmania c'est donc ce soir
on pensera bien évidemment à michel
berger également à daniel balavoine qui
était effectivement il faisait partie de
cette aventure et merci beaucoup merci
voilà une interview réalisée juste avant
ce journal avec france gall et puis
sachez que l'on a appris aujourd'hui la
mort du comédien bernard a l'air il
était âgé de 75 ans il avait mené une
carrière de
comédien et d'humoriste à la fois aux au
cinéma et au théâtre avant de terminer
journal je vous rappelle l'une des
informations du jour c'est la sanction
infligée par le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature aujourd'hui au juge fabrice
burgaud après avoir été reporté la
décision est finalement tombée et c'est
une simple réprimande qui lui était
signifié pour son instruction de
l'affairé d'outreau
une décision qui a suscité de nombreuses
réactions sept ans après ce terrible
fiasco judiciaire
voilà fin de ce journal merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve demain pour
le journal de 13h et 13h15 le samedi
tout de suite la météo isabelle martinez
20h35 starmania donc version 2009
je vous souhaite de passer une très
belle soirée et à demain j'espère
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr